I feel like I'm getting the raw end of
this deal so this week Ariel and I are
switching jobs
oh god oh boy I come up with a lot of
video concepts that Ned never uses and
I'm like why don't you use that and he's
like because it's not after glitter
beard came out I decided it would be
really gonna do it do I make sense Ariel
is self-employed and she owns her own
business she works well there are some
days where Ariel says oh it got lonely
that's always like but you get to be
home all day so like that's not a
problem right can work in your pajamas
so I am so excited to be working in his
office all day I'm gonna eat all the
snacks
Ariel says like oh being an office is
great you have free snacks but I can't
free snacks at home and those are snacks
that I actually like cuz I bought them
you know there's a lot to it than just
hanging out and getting snacks
gonna be like I could probably film a
video and like I don't have something
like that Ariel has no idea how long
videos actually take she might be able
to get away with convincing other people
that do work for her and it was actually
great at that maybe she's a better
producer than I am now I'm just we think
she's gonna be terrible let's bring on
the fireworks
oh why hello you were there the whole
time
hi beans this stuff does not need to
live on his desk so we're gonna clean up
first
it's good boy okay job bean you went
potty he's not important oh my god oh
you know what I am gonna put in a little
note yes
he's buying antiques and selling them to
rich people
yeah just got to Horseheads $50 yeah so
we need to make a video in a day you
know nope
do you gotta shoot no dear Karen we hope
you enjoy your silver plated candle
holder you guys no glitter beards right
yes okay now is the time to do my idea
of sticker beards
[Music]
okay so tables a sticker beards one
thing that's really in right now all
these pillows have tassels on them
extremely tassels are in right now yeah
I'll have any friends to eat lunch with
hey Jane how's it goin
not too much how do I shoot a nifty
video I recommend one hundred millimeter
lens nothing top-down but like you can
kind of get a little bit more mellow
later lens so now I'm going to inventory
the pieces that I bought as well as the
ones that aerial bot so how would I
describe these hey girl hi can you help
me up what's up I'm looking for a room
called Jackson oh yeah I can take you
there of mid-century brass horse head
bookends wooden racket that's like a
swan oh it's a it's a swan where's Ned
he's home he's gonna make himself yes so
so you're saying that I have all the
things that I need in this friend it's
like a game looks kind of ugly I have
all the doubts that this is gonna be
terrible I'll do this I'll do this if
you guys know I'm gonna do this we're
done I thought I had a couple more hours
left but I literally just looked at the
clock and the day is almost over see
that's pretty good lighting right yeah
it looks great
and I think even I feel like I was being
productive but I guess I was buying my
time see yes good for you I could stay
and edit this
but oh my god we swapped jobs for a day
harder than I expected it's tough being
your own boss I think what you do is
really cool that you've built your own
business well your job is roll hard a
always mentally challenging there's a
lot of things that can do behind the
scenes that I do not even realize I feel
like sicker beards
it could get made I don't think I am the
person to make it I think it's really
awesome that you brought your talent and
your skill into what I do
I really admire what you do but I'm glad
it's not what I do because I would get
fleeced all the time at the markets it's
nice to be able to leave work here work
[Music]